gardez la france au fond des yeux mais
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène ont un peu moins mais
si vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose un tout
petit détail
ce qui lui arrive à la baule
comme chaque semaine france info et
l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le temps
à travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine celle inattendue vous êtes
bien sûr les bienvenues une émission
très largement consacrée aux médias et à
la politique un puisque avec notre
invité jean louis debré nous allons
parler de l'humour en politique à mes
côtés camille d'auxerre ludivine lopez
journalistes présents la rédaction dina
bonjour à toutes les deux alors on
commence avec vous camille le magazine
elle a pris une décision majeure et va
arrêter de faire la promotion de la
fourrure animale oui les quarante et une
édition du magazine elle dans le monde
entier dont la version française
évidemment vont à partir du 1er janvier
prochain appliquer cette décision stop à
la fourrure animale dans les pages du
magazine
une décision qui s'inscrit selon la
direction dans une démarche écologique
contre la cruauté envers les animaux
la vraie fourrure animale n'est donc
plus à la mode nathanaël eh bien allez
dire ça à ce jour la liste de jeux mais
je soutiens totalement la décision de
rire évidemment évidemment mais allez
dire ça tout de même à ce journaliste de
1966 pour qui les fourrures porté par
les bêtes à l'est tout aussi bien aux
belles
la nature à luxueusement par et
certaines bêtes qu'on appelle sauvage
mais c'est heavy rain ne seront pas
seuls à porter leurs somptueuses parures
c'est ce que laisse supposer la
collection créée par carven attendons
nous à une sérieuse émulation l apo
d'oslo
[Musique]
oslo ap ou de slot
le mouvement dans la souplesse la
fourrure d'emprunt demeure aussi vivante
que l'autre teintes pastel d'un plumage
est un vison et bell auront le dernier
mot puisque ce sont elles qui font
revivre les plus belles des fous rires
mais attention aux trappeurs des champs
elysées voilà un petit peu nos misogynie
pas de compassion pour les animaux
s'étaient l'archipel gouf autre sujet
qui prête à discussion ludivine nous à
nous parler des miss france aujourd'hui
oui amandine petit miss france 2000 21
va rendre sa couronne ce week-end à
l'occasion du chat déjà il n'a pas dit
non ça passe vite une année nathanaël
donc elle va rendre sa couronne à
l'occasion du célèbre concours ces
dernières années l'élection a
fréquemment été remise en question
notamment pour l'image que le concours
renvoi de la femme certaines ex miss
france au contraire parle de véritable
tremplin pour leur carrière dans la mode
au cinéma à la télévision à l'image de
laury thilleman miss france 2011
c'est vrai que la vie post miss france a
changé comparé aux années 80 écoutez ces
lauréates c'était en 1983
les photographes de progresser en
général de faire des photos de nu mais
c'est assez normal dans la mesure où bon
pour faire du nu pour pour poser nue il
faut que la fille soit jolie donc par
définition miss france étant joly on
nous propose ça on me l'a proposé pour
playboy notamment j'ai refusé pour la
proposer pratiquement toutes les miss
france et ou reçues pour faire du nu sur
les magazines lui à l'époque où j'étais
miss france a même entendu avec
l'écharpé miss france a dit qu'il était
[Musique]
j'ai eu des propositions pour des romans
feuilletons mais pornographiques
rires entre filles et garçons
des perspectives d'avenir m'a très
flatteuse heureusement il salue je vais
rigoler ça c'est vrai mais heureusement
les temps ont changé nhat hanh et voilà
pour l'actualité de cette semaine que
s'est il passé à cette même période de
l'année par le passé pour le savoir il
faut regarder absolument le zapping de
l'inattendu
bonjour
image totalement impensable il ya encore
peu de temps celle du blanc fed avec de
clerck et du noir nelson mandela
recevant conjointement le prix nobel de
la paix le leader de la haine c'est
nelson mandela a affirmé qu'il acceptait
ce prix nobel dans l'espoir qu'ils
aideraient à la réconciliation nationale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dès l'été prochain la serre d'acier de
55 mètres de diamètre qui renfermera et
des f1 s'inscrira dans le paysage à côté
des parallélépipèdes de béton de et des
f2 les premiers kilowatts d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire partiront vers le
réseau de distribution à chinon ce
jour-là l'atome commencera à prendre la
relève des grands barrages et de leurs
usines hydroélectriques
[Musique]
toutes les télévisions et les chaînes de
radios américaines ont interrompu leurs
programmes pour annoncer la mort de john
lennon les admirateurs de lennon se
demande aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi ce
jeune américain de 25 ans david chapman
a tiré à bout portant sur john lennon
alors qu'il rentrait chez lui avec sa
femme après une séance d'enregistrement
qui que tu sois et doux que tu viennes
saint-nicolas tué avant tout celui dont
l'arrivée est fêtée avec la même joie
par les petits et par les grands
[Musique]
mais en soirée
depuis une semaine eric zemmour est
officiellement candidat à l'élection
présidentielle une candidature dans
laquelle camille il veut se détacher de
son passé de journaliste oui et dans sa
vidéo de candidature il disait ne plus
pouvoir se contenter de son rôle de
journaliste d'écrivains et de lanceurs
d'alert pour reprendre ses mots pourtant
si les candidats aujourd'hui à
l'élection présidentielle c'est quand
même largement grâce à son passé de
journaliste et surtout à ces 25
dernières années qu'il a passées à
écumer tous les plateaux télé pour se
faire un nom deux journalistes
éditorialistes à polémiste eric zemmour
il a affûté son style saisie des
polémiques tout ça sous l'oeil des
caméras
c'est une histoire qui n'a pas très bien
commencé marc zemmour info matin
1995 c'est la première apparition télé
d'eric zemmour il a 36 ans et il est
journaliste pour le quotidien info matin
un journal non étiquetés politiquement à
l'aise sur les plateaux télé il devient
un invité récurrent de l'émission de
michèle cotta il est ce qu'on appelle un
bon client aux opinions tranchées et une
ambiance délétère dans certaines
banlieues où des bandes de jeunes font
la loi les policiers ne rentre plus si
le pouvoir républicain ne se rétablit
pas danser dans ces zones là d'abord le
front national va exploser et s'est
terré parce que tout la plupart de ces
délinquants sont des jeunes de
l'immigration et donc sa dominance ça
donne un cocktail exposé exposés c'est
le début de la carrière télé d'eric
zemmour en cette année 95 année
présidentielle il est sur france 2 un
journaliste régulier des émissions
politiques oui ils interrogent des
personnalités de tous bords en parallèle
le journaliste éditorialiste kit info
matin et rejoint le figaro en 1996 eric
zemmour vient d'arriver figaro vous avez
le titre du figaro de baratin non non
pas encore il se veut aussi écrivain
essayiste et la nostalgie des duels sur
le pré alors qu'on ne peut plus faire ça
non je vois plus sortir mon épée voilà
malheureusement donc je sors mon mac
intosh et je tape sur mon ordinateur
comme un petit fou comme un petit fou il
règle ses comptes contre le pouvoir
judiciaire le déclin de la droite et en
l'an 2000 il s'associe à la star du
petit écran de l'époque patrick poivre
d'arvor ensemble ils écrivent un livre
pour dénoncer la transparence demandé
aux politiques sur leur vie privée
il faut aussi connaître leur vie privée
parce que parce que ça une évolution sur
leur décision politique sur la vie
politique dans le monde entier cette
évolution a déjà eu cours et c'est la
cerise et celles restées le dernier pays
a fait une exception culturelle
sympathie les justes en 2006 sa
notoriété fait un bond il rejoint on
n'est pas couché l'émission de laurent
ruquier sur france 2 et la même année il
règle ses comptes avec les femmes et
contre ce qu'ils appellent la
féminisation des hommes c'est la sortie
de son livre le premier sexe le cri d'un
journaliste et écrivain eric zemmour qui
met les pieds dans le plat dans un livre
en forme de manifeste
d'après lui les mâles sont en voie
d'extinction sur les plateaux télé eric
zemmour provoque ses interlocutrices
comme clémentine autain alors adjointe
au maire de paris s'agit simplement
expliqué que c'était mieux avant que
quand l'homme dominer les femmes et
pauvre femme dominée par les hommes mais
vous croyez que votre grand mère était
plus un plus idiote que vous vous croyez
que votre arrière grand mère était plus
idiote que vous non eric zemmour a fait
sa mue en quelques années il est devenu
l'un des polémistes les plus célèbres de
france sur les plateaux il développe ses
idées politiques
quitte à aller trop loin et à finir
devant les tribunaux dès l'instant qu'on
l'ait contrôlé 17 fois dans la journée
ça modifie le caractère 6 à tahrir et
moi on est content
parce que la plupart des trafiquants
sont noirs
depuis ses propos il ya une dizaine
d'années avec zemmour a beau multiplier
les phrases polémiques il a d'ailleurs
été poursuivis une quinzaine de fois
pour ce qu'il a pu dire oui et il a été
condamné deux fois pour provocation à la
haine raciale et pour provocation à la
haine religieuse alors ce qui est
intéressant quand on regarde toutes les
archives qui lie à d'eric zemmour à la
télévision c'est que depuis ses débuts
depuis 1995 quand il a commencé à être
invité il a tout de suite été un très
bon client et il a été invité par tous
il a même été invité par jean luc
delarue dans l'émission ça se discute
une émission sociétale de témoignages on
ne l'attendait pas forcément dans cette
émission sauf que ce soir là le sujet et
la politique mérite elle conte militent
encore pour l es ce que vous avez
sentiment qu'un homme politique pas de
la même manière assez aux électeurs de
belles général et à ses militants en
particulier ces mêmes tous leurs
problèmes c'est à dire qu'ils sont ils
ont ils ont deux façons de parler ils
ont deux discours non pas sur le fond
d'ailleurs forcément mais déjà dans la
forme et je dis que c'est un de leurs
problèmes car il se trouve avec la
télévision que les images de leurs
propos vis-à-vis des militants où ils
doivent un peu enflammé la salle où ils
doivent être un peu un peu un peu non
pas sectaires mais mais enthousiaste
donc forcément partial sont les
l'origine ces images et ces propos sont
reportés à la télévision avec un effet
d' impact énorme et des millions de gens
les reçoivent dans leur que dans la
confortablement assis dans leurs
fauteuils et 10 mai qu'elle sait que
sochaux cas c'est que cette hystérique
alors qu'en fait eux ils sont là pour
pour emporter l'adhésion l' enthousiasme
des militants qui sont venus pour ça et
c'est tout à leur honneur et du coup il
ya un décalage entre les deux voilà 1995
il connaissait donc déjà très bien les
effets de la télévision pour un
journaliste en manque de notoriété et
pour un homme politique voilà de zemmour
le journaliste à zemmour le candidat
merci beaucoup camille pour pour cet
éclairage
et nous allons parler maintenant de
l'humour en politique avec notre invité
jean louis debré bonjour député ministre
de l'intérieur président de l'assemblée
nationale président du conseil
constitutionnel
je veux oublier 35 ans de carrière
ponctuée de nombreuses petites phrases
et vous en avait recensé plusieurs dans
votre livre quand les politiques nous
faisait rire c'est aux collections
bouquins tient un mot d'abord sur le
prix décerné cette semaine à marlène
schiappa le prix de l'humour politique
décerné par le pré ce club de france
pour cette phrase prononcée sur radio j
c'était en décembre 2020 regarder on ne
va pas s'interdire les plans à trois
elles défendent est alors son projet de
loi visant à lutter contre la polygamie
seize hommes et femmes politiques
étaient en compétition pour des petites
phrases 1 pour ce prix est-ce que vous
pensez que cette victoire est méritée
peut-être pas pour cette phrase mais
pour beaucoup d'autres vous avez
d'ailleurs vous reçu oui oui j'ai reçu
c'était mon jour de gloire quand j'avais
dit je n'imagine pas la corse séparée du
continent vous n'étiez pas à votre
premier coup d'essai un des traits
d'humour vous en avez fait d'autres
comme celui ci en
1997 à l'époque vous réagissiez à la
télévision aux propos de la ministre de
l'environnement dominique voynet et de
la garde des sceaux elisabeth guigou
elle envisageait de dépénaliser le
cannabis
ces deux ministres
finalement
véhicules et l'attitude laxiste à
l'égard de la drogue et je me demande si
après avoir connu la gauche caviar nous
sommes pas en train de voir arriver la
gauche pétard on note l'effet de style
elle était préparée cette phrase pas du
tout et tout mais l'humour le plus drôle
c'est celui qui n'est pas préparée c'est
instinctif j'ai fait dans ma vie
politique j'ai fait énormément discours
on n'a retenu aucun sauf les petites
phrases et les politiques ont souvent
compris qu' on ne retenait que ce qui
attire l'attention ce qui capte
l'intérêt est donc les petites phrases
sont importantes alors jean louis debré
arrêtez moi si je me trompe mais j'ai
quand même l'impression que l'humour en
politique c'est une tradition
républicaine on le constate notamment en
lisant votre livre vous citer par
exemple cet échange dans l'hémicycle
entre georges clemenceau et jean jaurès
c'était en 1906
le premier dit à son adversaire vous
n'êtes pas le bon dieu j'en resterai
impliqué et vous vous n'êtes pas le
diable qu'en savez-vous lui rétorque
alors clemenceau je le fais bien oui
très bien alors c'est
ce que pour faire rire c'est surtout de
la grande rhétorique la wii s'est très
comment show est un très bon exemple
parce que là il va avoir un humour
méchant souvent mais le mouvement
politique et il avait très bien compris
comme d'autres l'ont compris après à
deux finalités à la fois faire mal
attaquer l'adversaire faire rire à ses
dépens la seule fois où j'ai fait rire
dans l'hémicycle c'était le début tu es
ma mère se mamère député et critique et
la constitution constitution écrite par
mon père et à ce moment je lui demande
la parole il pense que je vais le
contredire et je dis monsieur mamère je
préfère la constitution de mon père est
immédiatement s'ils voulaient les faits
et là tout le monde se met à rire on ne
sait plus qui l'a dit avant et après sa
plus importante et un autre un qui
maniait habilement la rhétorique
humoristique c'était le général de
gaulle vous le citez plusieurs fois dans
votre livre ses phrases cultes on les
retrouve dans les archives voici une
sélection de temps en temps on me dit on
me fait dire après vous
ce sera la pagaille
alors
quelques-uns suggère que l'on institut
la pagaille pluie
ce qui est à redouter à mon sens ce
n'est pas le vide politique c'est plutôt
le trop-plein
n'avait pas jugé bon de donner au peuple
français les informations qui lui aurait
permis de juger l'action de votre
gouvernement dans la sphère ben barka
c'est l'effet de mon inexpérience
comment vous portez-vous je vais vous
répondre tout de suite
pas mal je ne vais pas mal le furet
rassurez vous un jour je ne manquerai
pas de mourir et et vous voyez on se
souvient plus la conférence de presse on
se souvient plus du reste mais de ces
petites phrases et les retient est écrit
en trois mots ont déstabilisé par ce que
unes des autres fonctions pardon de
l'humour c'est de déstabiliser le
journaliste paris d'ailleurs on remarque
un il utilise beaucoup d'humour le
général de gaulle pour détourner les
questions des journalistes et après ça
ça aussi la conférence de presse a plus
intérêt après tout a été dit d'ailleurs
à l'époque on a repris que ces petites
phrases et il existe d'ailleurs des
maîtres en la matière dans les archives
vous me voyez sûrement venir françois
mitterrand jacques chirac valéry giscard
d'estaing georges marchais maîtriser cet
art à la perfection et ça a donné lieu à
de grands moments de télévision vous
raisonnez que je vais être 40 entendre
simplement y a qu'à entendre ça de la
bouche d'un léniniste le trouve que ça
ne manque pas de s'amuser à 40 ans je
suis très loin malheureusement d'avoir
les mêmes facilités intellectuelles que
le président de la république et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il est à l'elysée
probablement et
c'est certain que georges marchais
pratique l'union de la gauche
comme
l'union soviétique pratique la détente à
coups de canon en effet vous gérez le
ministère de la parole ceci depuis 1965
où depuis
1974 moi j'ai géré la france le concorde
ne tombe jamais en panne chauffe quand
monsieur mitterrand monte dedans je veux
dire c'est pas normal
j'ai envie de vrai c'était des phrases
percutantes bien ciselés sur fond de
sarcasmes stéphanie oui oui parce que
encore une fois tout le problème est de
atteinte d'atteindre son adversaire sans
être ni vulgaire ni
agressifs et donc quand on parle du
concorde en l'instant c'est fantastique
parce que il n'a pas agressé monsieur
mitterrand mais il a fait une phrase qui
fait que l'on rit vie monsieur
mitterrand c'est ça l'humour et c'est là
où tout le monde ne n'a pas cet humour
parce qu'il faut avoir la répartie je
vous ai senti quand même ému en
regardant ces images de jacques chirac
deux de georges marchais est-ce que
c'était mieux avant l'humour en polynôme
c'est toujours mieux avant on a toujours
la nostalgie du passé simplement ce que
ce que je constate en ce qui concerne
l'humour c'est que c'est pour ça que
j'ai mis le titre de mon livre au passé
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la télévision
continue l'entrée à partir de 1956 des
caméras dans l'hémicycle les réseaux
sociaux
sont qu'aujourd'hui on est prudent et
puis et puis les hommes 20 politique 10
à 30 40 50 ans avait une culture qui
leur permettait de une culture du verbe
et une culture de la présence on avait à
l'époque devrait orateurs tout de même
aujourd'hui
quel homme politique quelle femme
politique vous fait rire on parlait de
marlène schiappa tout à l'heure qui a
reçu le grand prix humour et politique
du press club de france est-ce qu'il y
en a d'autres j'écoutais très
objectivement ils me font plutôt pleurer
en ce moment je ne trouve pas de petites
phrases drôles
ils se prennent pour
des orateurs extraordinaire qui n'ont
pas parce que l'humour s'est aussi
construit dans un discours qui va
changer de rythme on est enfin d'humour
qui ont fait une phrase je reviens plus
en fait on a plus c'est grand orateur et
dans votre livre vous dites vous vous
contentez de ses lapsus un nombreux dans
l'hémicycle en meeting ou en interview
ils sont quand même assez savoureux
avouons le et ça méritait bien un petit
florilège il est légitime que nos
concitoyens soient inquiets s'agissant
des autorisations qui ont été données en
matière d'exploration et d'exploitation
de gisements de gaz de shit de schiste
c'est donc un projet extrêmement vague
vaste et c'est ça l'essentiel
aujourd'hui sur l'access
car le gode électoral dit clairement la
france de toute éternité a toujours été
du côté des opprimés et toujours été du
côté des dictateurs sans que vous-même
qui étiez alors conseiller de françois
dont la tête est président ça moi l'abc
ses ministres
mesdames et messieurs les retraités
monsieur le député jean-philippe nuit
on était plutôt l'un dans le registre de
l'humour involontaire
est ce que finalement les politiques
aujourd'hui vous considérer qu'ils ont
moins d'humour est-ce que c'est lié au
contexte sanitaire écologistes
écologique alors cessé c'est lié aussi
au fait que jadis et encore 30 ans on
improvise et or aujourd'hui les
parlementaires sont entourés de
collaborateurs qui leur écrire un papier
iliz papier souhait aujourd'hui il ya
plus de spontanéité parce qu'on a peur
et puis à trop de collaborateurs et puis
encore une fois j'ai dit à leurs la
culture la culture du débat n'est plus
là est-ce que c'est finalement le rôle
des des politiques des chefs d'état
d'être d'être drôle même dans un
discours depuis deux ans on est quand
même dans des dents un sujet extrêmement
extrêmement lourd il ya des moments où
il faut être graves mais quand vous
essayez de faire passer un message
quand vous essayer d'attirer quand vous
passez devant la télévision et plusieurs
millions de personnes
il a un message à délivrer mais il ya
toujours aussi un message d'optimisme
car un homme politique ne veux pas semer
le pessimisme est donc il faut trouver
c'est là tout l'art retrouver l'humour
qui ne choque pas mais qui
dit pas où il est sympathique et l'a dit
les choses gras mais il a aussi évoqué
l'avenir avec humour d'ailleurs parmi
les derniers chefs d'état il y en a un
qui a fait ses preuves en matière
d'humour c'est françois hollande son
autodérision c'est la palissade ces
affirmations évident qui prête à rire
ses phrases sarcastique particulièrement
envers ses adversaires porte même un nom
leo landry comme les raffarinade à une
autre époque l'ancien président a
plusieurs fois été récompensée au prix
de l'humour politique en novembre 2017
c'était pour l'ensemble de sa carrière
d'humoriste il est venu chercher les le
prix exactement il est venu chercher son
prix évidemment avec beaucoup d'humour
je suis bien compris que c'était
l'ensemble de mon oeuvre qui étaient
salués
soir
de ce domaine là j'ai toujours conçu
l'humour comme un moyen de faire passer
des idées ou en tout cas des arguments
l'humour n'est pas une facétie l'humour
c'est une méthode qui consiste
effectivement en une formule piquante
d'en dire davantage que dans un discours
laborieux et l'humour c'est aussi une
façon de partager et pas simplement une
forme de distanciation comme on le dit
souvent il a raison françois hollande
l'humour ça sert aussi à fédérer
moralité
c'est que ça permet de rassembler des
hommes des femmes qui ne sont pas
forcément des militants des
sympathisants faire rire faire rire
faire sourire semer un peu d'espoir
alors l'on était un maître il est un
maître c'est une tactique aussi pour
être populaire d'utiliser l'humour c'est
une tactique politique au final écoutez
ça rend plutôt sympathique or la
politique c'est d'apparaître aux
électrices et aux électeurs sympathique
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on dit n'importe
quoi mais la sympathie dans un monde de
brutes dans un monde individualiste
quelqu'un qui vient
télévision qu'il commence à vous casser
les pieds et qui est qu'il vous en
donnerons on zappe quand on sait que moi
sourire quand on sait qu'on va passer un
bon moment eh ben on écoute jean louis
debré merci de nous avoir fait partager
vos souvenirs et vos sourires aussi je
rappelle le titre de votre livre quand
les politiques nous faisait rire aux
éditions bouquin merci également à vous
ludivine de nous avoir rassemblé ces
bons moments de l'histoire de la
télévision on se quitte avec notre
traditionnel pépites qui devrait vous
plaire jean louis debré en 1959 les
humoristes pierre dac et francis blanche
était à la tête d'un nouveau parti le
parti d'en rire
oui nathan parti martine aubry oui oui
c'est le parti de tous ceux qui n'ont
pas pris à partie notre défi paris re
oui c'est le parti de tout ce qui leur a
pris le car son père puis nous avons
pris le parti
de cette fois pas partie
parti
derrière ça me marty en trois parties
notre d'appeler
ça le parti de tous ceux qui n'ont pas
pris de partout
c'est pourquoi il a retiré deux
frappeurs
on se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine sur le canal 27 toute la
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit ceux de yahoo se dépense info vous
pouvez venir aussi monsieur debré
émission préparée grâce à nos
documentaliste elles sont précieuses
quand on voit leur travail et mini
galtier est clair brûlés alors merci à
elle et merci à vous d'être là chaque
semaine
[Musique]